[Musique]
c'est une autre tempête hivernale à
sainte flavie les vents sont violents
les vagues sont fortes
damien rue est inquiet il se souvient de
ce qu'il a vécu fameux d'assaut terrain
après la côte et la beauté chaque côté
en allant vers l'est c'était en décembre
2010 partout dans l'est du québec des
grandes marées ont fait des ravages
depuis celui qui était maire de
sainte-flavie à l'époque créé d'autres
tempêtes créé pour sa maison son
commerce la quiétude combi en même temps
pilote la beauté de tout le paysage
combien l'année mais en même temps il ya
ceux qui nous qui nous pend au bout du
nez à sainte-flavie plus de 200 maisons
sont à risque en raison des tempêtes et
de l'érosion des berges
ici on perd en moyenne de 15 à 5 cm de
littoral par eni les risques sont telles
qu'on envisage de déménager ou de
carrément démolir certaines maisons
l'avenir ce ne soit pas un autre
on se bat qui est la valeur des
propriétés à souk naâmane sabots des
profits c'est certain
les gens sainte-flavie sont attachés au
fleuve mais bientôt on va les rencontrer
pour leur parler des risques de vivre
ici de vivre si près du fleuve
ils auront donc un choix à faire et ce
sera difficile pour eux partir ou encore
rester bonjour c'est géraldine la
municipalité de sainte-flavie géraldine
fait de la sensibilisation auprès des
gens qui habitent dans la zone à risque
aujourd'hui elle est chez madame
gallagher s'est-elle éventuellement qui
aura la tâche d'aider les propriétaires
à faire des choix est ce que vous
décrivez c'est actuellement cours pied
j'espère que d'ici la fin du mois on
pourra prévenir les citoyens sur une
décision prise à ce moment c'est une
décision de vie le dilemme sera d'autant
plus déchirant qu'une telle offre
pourrait ne jamais revenir pour les
citoyens selon nos informations le
gouvernement du québec s'apprête à
offrir une aide financière de 5 millions
et demi de dollars aux propriétaires des
25 maisons les plus à risque ce qui
équivaut à 220 1000 $ par résidence
c'est un programme de prévention de la
sécurité publique qui va leur offrir
soit de déplacer de manière préventive
leur maison donc on l'apprend puis on la
met sur un terrain qui est plus
sécuritaire soit ont démoli leurs
maisons soient et restent là
suite à 2010 n'a eu des traumatismes
quand même suite à cette tempête là où
les gens ont dû prendre des décisions
rapidement la montage du programme qui
va arriver ce qu'on va leur laisser le
temps de choisir
huguette lacerte vie dans la zone à
risque sa maison elle a acheté six mois
seulement avant la grande tempête de
2010 ça vaut le coup de vis et mais ce
que je leur ferais je pense que je serai
plus sage investir et mon argent trop
lent parce que là maintenant c'est fini
une maison s'envole elle crée le pire à
chaque tempête pourtant elle n'a pas
l'intention de partir tu as l'âge qu'on
a on s'envole mais c'est pas qu'on vive
enquête je pensais pas vivre ici
définissez vos impôts non jetable mal
tellement tellement certaine que ça va
se reproduire et d'agendas est ce que je
prenais pas pour s'assurer que les gens
touchés restent dans son village le
maire actuel de sainte-flavie va créer
un nouveau développement résidentiel
ici sur ces terrains suite aux grandes
marées 2010 et qu'il y avait très peu de
terrains disponibles à sainte flavie qui
permettait à l'époque dans l'urgence de
relocaliser des maisons les gens avaient
plutôt choisi massivement à 26 reprises
de démolir leur maison
26 maisons ont été démolies trail ont
été déplacées le gouvernement du québec
était probablement mal préparés en 2010
à réagir à une réalité telle qu'elle est
vécue qui était quand même cataclysme
important pour tout l'est du québec pour
lui il n'ya aucun doute
les changements climatiques sont en
train de transformer son village on la
connaît la mer on sait qu'elle va être
présenté dans 50 ans mais le visage de
sainte flavie va carrément être
différent
un village dont la moitié de la
population vit pour l'instant
près du fleuve
[Musique]